June 2010 I landed for the first time in
Rome Italy I wasn't there to sightsee I
was there to solve world hunger that's
right
I was a 25 year old PhD student armed
with the prototype tool developed back
at my university and I was going to help
the World Food Program fix hunger so I
strode into the headquarters building
and my eyes scanned the row of UN flags
and I smiled as I thought to myself the
engineer is here give me your data I'm
gonna optimize everything tell me the
food that you've purchased tell me where
it's going and when it needs to be there
and I'm gonna tell you the shortest
fastest cheapest best set of routes to
take for the food we're going to save
money we're going to avoid delays and
disruptions and bottom line we're gonna
save lives
you're welcome I thought it was going to
take 12 months ok maybe even 13 this is
not quite how it panned out just a
couple of months into the project my
French boss he told me you know Mallory
it's a good idea but the data you need
for your algorithms is not there it's
the right idea but at the wrong time and
the right idea at the wrong time is the
wrong idea project over I was crushed
when I look back now on that first
summer in Rome and I see how much has
changed over the past six years it is an
absolute transformation it's a coming of
age for bringing data into the
humanitarian world it's exciting it's
inspiring but we're not there yet
embrace yourself executives because I'm
going to be putting companies on the hot
seat to step up and play the role that I
know
they can my experience is back in Rome
proof using data you can save lives okay
not that first attempt but eventually we
got there let me paint the picture for
you imagine that you have to plan
breakfast lunch and dinner
for 500,000 people and you only have a
certain budget to do it say six and a
half million dollars per month well what
should you do what's the best way to
handle it should you buy rice wheat
chickpea oil how much it sounds simple
it's not you have 30 possible foods and
you have to pick five of them that's
already over 140,000 different
combinations then for each food that you
pick need to sit decide how much you'll
buy where you're going to get it from
where you're going to store it how long
it's going to take to get there and you
need to look at all the different
transportation routes as well and that's
already over 900 million options if you
considered each option for a single
second that would take you over 28 years
to get through 900 million options so we
created a tool that allowed decision
makers to weed through all 900 million
options in just a matter of days it
turned out to be incredibly successful
in an operation in Iraq we saved 17
percent of the costs and this meant that
you had the ability to feed an
additional 80,000 people it's all thanks
to the use of data and modeling complex
systems but we didn't do it alone the
unit that I worked with in Rome they
were unique they believed in
collaboration they brought in the
academic world they brought in companies
and if we really want to make big
changes in big problems like world
hunger we need everybody to the table we
need the data people from humanitarian
organizations leading the way and
orchestrating just the right types of
engagements with academics with
governments and there's one group that's
not being leveraged in the way that it
should be did you guess it
companies companies have a major role to
play in fixing the big problems in our
world I've been in the private sector
for two years now I've seen what
companies can do and I've seen what
companies aren't doing
I think there's three main ways that we
can fill that gap by donating data by
donating decision scientists and by
donating donating technology to gather
new sources of data this is data
philanthropy and it's the future of
corporate social responsibility bonus it
also makes good business sense companies
today they collect mountains of data so
the first thing they can do is start
donating that data some companies are
already doing it take for example a
major telecom company they open up their
data in Senegal on the Ivory Coast and
research researchers discovered that if
you look at the patterns in the pings to
the cellphone towers you can see where
people are traveling and that can tell
you things like where malaria might
spread and you can make predictions with
it or take for example an innovative
satellite company they opened up their
data and donated it with that data you
could track how droughts are impacting
food production with that you can
actually trigger aid funding before a
crisis can happen this is a great start
there's important insights just locked
away in company data and yes you need to
be very careful you need to respect
privacy concerns for example by
anonymizing the data but even if the
floodgates opened up and even if all
companies donated their data its
academics to NGOs to humanitarian
organisations it wouldn't be enough to
harness that full impact of data for
humanitarian goals why
to unlock insights and data you need
decision scientists decision scientists
are people like me they take the data
they clean it up transform it and put it
into a useful algorithm that's made
that's the best choice to address the
business need at hand in the world of
humanitarian aid there are very few
decision scientists most of them work
for companies so that's the second thing
that companies need to do in addition to
donating their data they need to donate
their decision scientists now companies
will say ah don't take our decision
scientists from us we need every spare
second of their time but there's a way
if a company was going to donate a block
of a decision scientists time it would
actually make more sense to spread out
that block of
over long period say for example five
years this might only amount to a couple
of hours per month which a company would
hardly miss but what it enables is
really important long-term partnerships
long term partnerships allow you to
build relationships to get to know the
data to really understand it and to
start to understand the needs and
challenges that the humanitarian
organization is facing in Rome at the
World Food Programme this took us five
years to do five years that first three
years okay that was just what we
couldn't solve for then there was two
years after that of her finding and
implementing the tool like in the
operations in Iraq and other countries I
don't think that's an unrealistic
timeline when it comes to using data to
make operational changes it's an
investment it requires patience but the
types of results that can be produced
are undeniable in our case it was the
ability to feed tens of thousands more
people so we have donating data we have
donating decision scientists and there's
actually a third way that companies can
help donating technology to capture new
sources of data you see there's a lot of
things we just don't have data on right
now Syrian refugees are flooding into
Greece and the UN refugee agency they
have their hands full the current system
for tracking people is paper and pencil
and what that means is that when a
mother and her five children walk into
the camp headquarters is essentially
blind to this moment that's all going to
change in the next few weeks thanks to
private sector collaboration there's
going to be a new system based on
donated package tracking technology from
the logistics company that I work for
with this new system there will be a
data trail so you know exactly the
moment when that mother and her children
walk into the camp and even more you
know if she's going to have supplies
this month and the next information
visibility drives efficiency for
companies using technology to gather
important data it's like bread and
butter they've been doing it for years
and it's led to major operational
efficiency improvements just try to
imagine your favorite beverage company
trying to plan their inventory and not
knowing how many bottles were on the
shelves it's absurd data drives better
to say
now if you're representing a company and
you're pragmatic and not just idealistic
you might be saying to yourself okay
this is all great Mallory but why should
I want to be involved well for one thing
beyond the good PR humanitarian aid is a
twenty four billion dollar sector and
there's over five billion people maybe
your next customers that live in the
developing world further companies that
are engaging in data philanthropy
they're finding new insights locked away
in their data take for example a credit
card company that's opened up a sinner
that functions as a hub for academics
for NGOs and governments all working
together they're looking at information
in credit card swipes and using that to
find insights about how households in
India live work earn and spend for the
humanitarian world this provides
information about how you might bring
people out of poverty but for companies
it's providing insights about your
customers and potential customers in
India it's a win all around now for me
what I find exciting about data
philanthropy donating data donating
decision scientists and donating
technology it's what it means for young
professionals like me who are choosing
to work at companies studies show that
the next generation of the workforce
care about having their work make a
bigger impact we want to make a
difference and so through data
philanthropy companies can actually help
engage and retain their decision
scientists and that's a big deal for a
profession that's in high demand data
philanthropy makes good business sense
and it also can help revolutionize the
humanitarian world if we coordinated the
planning and logistics across all of the
major facets of a humanitarian operation
we could feed clothe and shelter
hundreds of thousands more people and
companies need to step up and play the
role that I know they can in bringing
about this revolution you've probably
heard of the same food for thought well
this is literally thought for food it
finally is the right idea at the right
time
three magnifique thank you